all right this is absolutely bizarre
rudy guiliani or Giuliani Donald Trump's
personal attorney may be former I guess
we don't really know at this point
what's going on Rudy appeared on TV on
none other than Fox News he was
interviewed by Trump brown-noser Maria
Bartiromo
and those are there there are two
different things here that are bonkers
about this video first is what Rudy
Giuliani says because Rudy Giuliani now
is jumping on the train and he is going
on TV and pushing chloroquine as a
treatment for coronavirus Rudy is not a
doctor Trump is not a doctor actual
doctors are saying it's worth trying in
controlled trials along with dozens of
other things but the early results seem
very 50/50 about chloroquine of course
if Trump is saying it then everybody
around Trump is saying it so Rudy
Giuliani now recommending medications on
TV so we're gonna play that but the
other crazy thing about this video is
that Rudy Giuliani looks like he's had
half of a haircut in this video what I
mean is one side of Rudy Giuliani's head
looks like he has a short haircut like
he's almost shaved his head the other
side doesn't it's very odd so if you're
watching look at the left side of Rudy's
head meaning the right side of your
screen and you'll see a ton of hair
that's all puffed up and his hair on the
right side of his head your left looking
at the screen is gone it's a very weird
thing in contributing to Rudy Giuliani's
generally increasingly disheveled
appearance anyway let's go to the
substance now I think we should let
doctors decide whether we should use
hydrochloric win not the National
bureaucracy
you know this disease can kill you
and if hydrochloric win has side effects
none of which are death by the way then
those side effects I may want to endure
because of the risk of death and it may
be different if I'm 25 or if I'm 75
those choices should be given to doctors
not to the bureaucrats in Washington who
want to go through three blind tests
when we finished the three blind tests
you know most of America could be gone
and they sit there in an ivory tower
whereas the guy sitting at Mount Sinai
in hospital with the person walking in
who's 65 year old 65 years old 104
temperature and I set one there just the
other day first thing they did before
they even talked to him is give him
hydroxychloroquine and it's banned in
New York by the governor why is the
governor banning it everything shows
that it works everything shows that its
side effects don't bother you until you
take it for a month or two for chronic
illness like rheumatoid arthritis or
lupus
five administration's of it so far no
side effects Rudy says let's let doctors
decide that's who is deciding we don't
need Rudy and Trump saying try it and
this is the new game that they're
playing they're acting like it's
bureaucrats who are making decisions
about medications that's not true the
FDA has approved for emergency use
really quickly emergency use of
chloroquine if determined appropriate by
a doctor the side effects are never
death Rudy says that's wrong and in fact
there's something called chloroquine
poisoning people with heart problems can
end up dying from taking doses of
chloroquine there are peer-reviewed
studies about this Rudy says cleric wins
banned in New York that's not true they
are repeating this but it is not true
New York and some other states have
restricted access to chloroquine to
avoid stockpiling of the drug there are
exemptions for clinical trials there are
exemptions for patients hospitalized
with coronavirus if the doctor
determines it's appropriate these are
all lies and as you all know I've been
talking about chloroquine longer than
Trump I have been telling you this is
one of dozens of possible treatments we
want to test it but Trump now being so
in favor of it
Rudy being so in favor of it we found
out Novartis which manufactures it paid
Michael Cohen a million dollars for
access to Trump when we look at this
from a political perspective it's things
to high heaven from a medical
perspective chloroquine should be try
safely when determined by doctors as one
of many RCTs randomized clinical trials
and we should see what comes of it and
it just doesn't stop on fox news with
the chloroquine i have another great
example for you
from fox news in trying to keep the prop
the propaganda narrative set by Donald
Trump going Fox News brought on a doctor
to talk about chloroquine unfortunately
they brought on the wrong doctor I think
you're really going to like this this is
an interview with dr. William Haseltine
William Haseltine was interviewed by Fox
host Dana Perino Dana Perino you might
remember was george w bush's press
secretary at one point Haseltine is a
well known biologist entrepreneur
philanthropist he's a 75 year old guy
now did very important work on hiv/aids
did important work on the human genome
taught at Harvard Medical School this is
a serious guy he's serious in the
medical world he's serious in the
business world and he does not take Dana
Perino's BS when she now tries to keep
pushing chloroquine as a possible
coronavirus treatment which is exactly
what Donald Trump has been doing let's
get to dr. Haseltine starting to shut
down Dana Perino sir can you tell me
your thoughts about this draw everybody
wants to find a cure or a treatment or a
therapy for coronavirus what do you
think about the drug that is used
normally to treat malaria thank you for
the question and it's sad to me that
people are promoting that drug we know
already from studies at best it will
have a very mild effect at very best
there are studies that conflict a little
bit one from the other one concludes it
has no effect you have they can close it
has a mild effect the net result is
whatever effect it has it will be very
mild that drug has been used for years
against many other
to no effect they think that makes me
sad about that story is some people may
take it who are in other medications who
are other underlying conditions and they
have very serious even life-threatening
consequences it is not something to take
unless a doctor prescribes it so notice
that in 45 seconds he refutes just about
everything that Donald Trump has been
saying Trump says what do you have to
lose
doctor Haseltine explains you can lose
your life it has life-threatening side
effects for some people Trump says it's
working really well
doctor Haseltine explains there are
conflicting reports but it is either
mild or no impact and here Dana Perino
continues pushing because this is not
going well to push Trump's narrative and
now dr. Haseltine straight up calls some
of the claims nonsense and says it is
reminiscent of quack cures when people
continue to push this and what about the
I know you don't go by anecdotal
evidence but there are stories of people
saying that they've had this Lazarus
effect by using this drug that is
nonsense
complete and utter nonsense and in any
situation there are always going to be
people who promote one kind of quack
cure or another and there are Lazarus
effects you know every epidemic I've
ever looked at it's always the case let
me just repeat we know that at very best
this drug will have a very mild effect
on changing the course of the disease if
it has any effect at all that is what
the data has shown so far and I am
convinced that that's what further
studies will show and it's not without
adverse consequence it is irresponsible
to promote this drug at this time in
absolutely the most direct terms so far
a doctor on Fox News saying promoting
this like an exciting new product is
irresponsible and Dana Perino simply
unable to say much else because she's
not a doctor in the end and she could
only reference this
vague anecdotal evidence and that's
another fox news segment gone wrong once
again so you have to understand Fox News
is invested in the Trump narrative when
Trump was downplaying coronavirus Fox
was downplaying coronavirus when Trump
started using the word hoax in a coy way
related to coronavirus Fox News started
using the word hoax Fox has been one of
the biggest promoters of chloroquine
allowing 109 claims during a three day
period in March about how well the drug
functions with only 15 claims during
that same three-day period which cast
any doubt on the efficacy of chloroquine
to treat coronavirus they even bring on
TV doctors people very different than
doctor Haseltine including dr. oz to
promote chloroquine and so when we see a
real doctor who is a serious person
smack down a Fox News host it is very
entertaining but the most important
thing is we don't go any farther one way
or the other than what the science says
dr. Haseltine may be right it may have a
small effect there are dozens of things
being tested we should go through the
process with everything and not pick one
drug to promote like a miracle cure
which is what Donald Trump has been
doing if it turns out chloroquine with
or without azithromycin works well for
certain patient profiles for example or
at certain stages of the disease that's
great
remember I've been talking about
chloroquine and as a thorough Meissen
much longer than Donald Trump has but
we've got to follow the science we can't
turn this into a propaganda fest we
don't pick a medication like a sports
team and promote it no matter what the
facts are good for dr. Haseltine for
setting dr. Perino straight i can't
imagine he will be invited back on the
program
we continue to cover the trials of
various medications on the David Pakman
show Instagram page at David Pakman show
make sure you're following we'll be back
right after this
okay so we're continuing our tour
through the delusions of Fox News today
I have two Fox News
religious clips and one is an example of
a religious leader being responsible
about coronavirus that's the first one
the second foxnews coronavirus religious
clip is a religious not being completely
irresponsible about coronavirus okay so
let's start remember that Donald Trump
at one point wanted the country opened
by Easter and it's a sort of god complex
gone wrong I've talked about this before
Trump seeing himself as a sort of Jesus
like figure resurrecting the country on
Eastern Easter much like the biblical
Easter story of Jesus's resurrection now
ultimately it didn't work would be
hugely dangerous to reopen the country
this Sunday that's when Easter is
imagined we're not even at the peak yet
Trump was thinking about reopening but
there's a lot of really big evangelical
churches that don't care they keep
gathering huge crowds and Fox News host
Laura Ingraham really wants religious
gatherings to continue because otherwise
as she says nobody will gather to pray
until out Anthony foul she says it's
okay which to me makes sense right I
mean like don't we need doctors and not
pastors deciding when it's safe to
gather in huge groups so check out Laura
Ingraham on her show truly vile while
interviewing a Catholic priest father
Marie and then some other guy I don't
know who the other guy is but he doesn't
speak during this segment check it out
yeah I think father Marie a lot of
people especially the working-class
people of our country the people who pay
the bills who don't get a lot of
accolades people that a lot of us came
from they're the one this is like the
time where they need a public
affirmation of their faith it's it's all
well and good to say stay at home I
heard into some priests on TV might have
even been on our network saying oh it's
the domestic Church you know yeah I get
that but it's this is this is Holy Week
and and just to say because the bishops
say you can't I don't know I've got to
say out blessing the palms public you
know blessings people far apart
otherwise you know maybe we won't have
mass until Anthony Fauci says it's okay
after Christmas or something I mean I
guess what the bishops be okay with that
I don't know the people who were
they need to go to church and laura
ingraham seems incredulous that wait
people are staying home during Holy Week
how is this possible
so there's laura ingraham being insane
but now we get to father Murray's
response father Murray's response is
absolutely correct
now there's two funny little things that
you'll notice and father Murray's
response one is that he refers to
coronavirus as Korah known a virus which
I just love it's extraordinarily
endearing and as he does it his head
phone also falls out of his right ear so
a lot of things visually going wrong for
father Murray but he is absolutely right
and doing the responsible thing and for
that he should be commended take a look
and they put you know that disease into
their congregation and so many people
have died in Italy and you know we don't
want to repeat that here you have to get
ahead of the curve you can't just keep
things you know as as they were and it's
regretful but you know whatever you do
the least of my bread and you do to me
if you sacrifice going to mass so that
people don't get sick I think that's a
form of praising God so the Catholic
priest pointing out essentially stay the
hell home actually saying the
responsible thing you should stay home
priests have died in Italy this is not
good staying home to avoid being sick is
good God's not going to be bad God's not
going to punish you so good for father
Marie here he's doing absolutely the the
correct thing and unfortunately on Fox
News we continue to see every dangerous
narrative that is being parodied by
Trump and people around him repeated ad
nauseam chloroquine chloroquine
chloroquine what do you have to lose
take it take it take it we got to go to
church prayer is so important keep
tithing keep donating to your church so
good for father Marie here for getting
involved in saying no that's the wrong
thing
a responsible example of a religious
leader commenting on what has to be done
about coronavirus unfortunately now we
get to the irresponsible one
okay last FoxNews clip for the day I'm
going to play for you today the video
that should be at the top of the list of
videos to scrub from the internet if you
are the Trump administration and if you
were Fox News it is a video of a woman
named Kaylee McKenna nee who is a press
secretary for Donald Trump's 2020
campaign she's been around for a while
commenting on politics she's a big
Christian right winger often saying
painfully dumb things she went on Fox
News a few weeks ago and said not that
the virus wouldn't be a big deal here in
the United States because of something
about its rate of spread or its death
rate or because of something about
infectious disease or a medication she
went on and said on Fox News Donald
Trump is America first he's not going to
allow a virus like coronavirus to come
here and she added that's refreshing
compared to the Obama administration
this is what happens when you join a
cult and she is in a cult and that's the
right word here so the Trump campaign
has been working hard to scrub videos
from the Internet of Trump referring to
the virus as a hoax if I were them I
would do everything I can to get this
video off the internet we're gonna try
to make it a little bit harder by
playing the video for you now this is
Kaylee McKenna knee being interviewed by
former Fox host trish regan trish regan
has since been fired after going on her
own unhinged rant about the corona virus
hoax
this is the clip in question take a look
looking at the corona virus and the
president saying you know look we're not
gonna take people in from china right
now i mean isn't it just a matter of
protecting us our national security
really being at stake and he's sort of
the last line of defense there or
firstly I should say absolutely this
president will always put America first
he will always protect American citizens
we will not see diseases like the corona
virus come here
we will not see terrorism come here and
isn't that refreshing when can
resting it with the awful presidency at
President Obama Kaylee mcenamey thank
you so much good to see you thank you
trish regan there gleefully welcoming
this absolutely abortive and fetid claim
by Kaylee McKenna knee this to me is
more highly weaponized than the dumb
medical arguments that float around
because this is the type of argument
that's actually immune to reality and
facts it's an argument like we've seen
so let me give you an example of
arguments that we've seen this is less
of a concern than the flu because it is
less deadly that's wrong but it's not
immune to the facts right most of the
people or many of the people saying it
don't care about the facts but you can
deal with it you can say oh well you
know the flu death rate is 0.15 the
death rate for the virus appears to be
between 0.7 and 1.5 it's somewhere
between five and ten times deadlier okay
you don't need the social distance some
of them have said okay here's evidence
that you do state social distancing or
seeing a lower rate of case growth or
whatever again many people don't care
about the facts but you can have a
conversation about it
Kaylee's off the deep end in cult world
trump is America first so he won't allow
the coronavirus into the u.s. unlike
awful Obama that's immune from fact
you're not operating in the real world
and Kaleigh often doesn't operate in the
real world just check out her videos
about abortion and trish regan also
doesn't operate in the real world so
it's really a perfect fit actually for
the fox news audience now after this
clip started to get attention some
spokesperson for Trump said you know
know know what Kaley meant was Trump
won't allow the virus to come here from
China because he banned travel okay well
Trump banned China travel when Europe
was already actually the focus of the
disease he was always ten steps behind
and maybe most importantly even after
Trump banned travel from China flights
from China kept coming in for a full
week after that point so this is really
ugly weaponized ignorant that were up
against we are up against a virally
spreading fire
and we're up against virally spreading
disinformation and we're up against
people who seemed to have been
inoculated against fact and reason and
that's a really tough place to be okay I
have a challenge for you today
play along I want you to tell me whether
what I'm about to play for you is
evidence of Donald Trump lying which he
does often or is it evidence of Donald
Trump glitching badly and losing his
memory of what he said just minutes
earlier during yesterday's coronavirus
White House press briefing so let's take
a look at the evidence the new scapegoat
for the Trump administration around
coronavirus is the whu-oh the World
Health Organization we've seen this
develop and grow virally for lack of a
better term over the last 48 to 72 hours
the Trump administration has realized
hey let's just constantly say that
everything bad that happened is the
fault of the w-h-o now there's plenty of
blame to go around
I've been critical of the w-h-o but the
Trump administration is going beyond
that and they are focusing their blame
singularly on the w-h-o while Trump
continues to insist he did everything
perfectly he did everything quickly he
had the best response of any country
obviously not true so let's get to the
video listen to what Trump says here
very very clearly he says we are going
to put a hold on the money that we send
to the w-h-o we are going to do that
very strongly it's going to be a very
powerful hold of the money listen to
Trump saying it coming out of his own
mouth World Health Organization because
they really are they called it wrong
they call it wrong they really they
missed the call they could have called
it months earlier they would have known
and they should have known and they
probably didn't know so we'll be looking
into that very carefully and we're gonna
put a hold on money spent to the w-h-o
we're gonna put a very powerful hold on
it okay so just so we're really clear
here this is just the sentence where
Trump says we are holding the money
from the whu-oh we are not sending the
money and we're gonna put a hold on
money spent to the w-h-o we're gonna put
a very powerful hold on it so we're all
on the same page Trump says we're
putting a very powerful hold on the
money to the w-h-o a few minutes go by a
reporter says you know we're in the
middle of a pandemic is this really a
good time to stop sending money to the
w-h-o and Trump says a hold who said
anything about a hold I never said that
this is minutes later ladies and
gentlemen take a listen so it's the time
to freeze funding to the WHL during a
pandemic I mean I'm not saying I'm going
to do it but we're going to look at it
you did we give a tremendous no I didn't
I said we're gonna look at it we're
going to investigate it we're gonna look
at it but we will look at ending funding
yeah because you know what they called
it wrong and if you look back over the
years even they're very much everything
seems to be very biased toward China I
never said that and reporters
incredulous start yelling yes you did
and he did one more time here is what
Donald Trump said just minutes earlier
and we're gonna put a hold on money
spent to the w-h-o we're gonna put a
very powerful hold on it and then
minutes later Donald Trump denying that
he ever said it so it's the time to
freeze funding to the WHL during a
pandemic we're gonna look at it we're
going to investigate it we're gonna look
at it so you all know what my question
is is this evidence that Donald Trump's
brain function is so poor that he really
has no recollection that minutes earlier
he said we're putting a very powerful
hold on the money or is Trump simply
lying is he trying to rewrite history in
real time what explains this I want you
to let me know your thoughts I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman lying memory glitch
something else I don't know the answer
you let me know I have today the
perfect sort of mind meld for you of two
completely lunatic factions who have
designated themselves coronavirus
experts in recent weeks you've got Fox
News hosts and then you've got religious
nuts
now when I say religious nuts I don't
mean everybody who's religious in the
last segment we had Catholic priest
Father Murry saying stay the hell home
no churches on Easter priests are dying
you've got to do the responsible thing
so when I say religious nuts I don't
mean anybody who's religious I'm talking
specifically about religious nuts so on
the one hand we've previously mentioned
absolutely unhinged Fox News former
judge Jeanine Pirro including her
seemingly drunk broadcast last week or
the week before if that's on on one side
on the other side we've talked about
these religious grifters talking about
sin is what caused coronavirus prayer is
the solution to coronavirus this clip
today is a combination of the two top
religious grifter franklin graham son of
the late billy graham a family of
Christian evangelists was invited on to
judge Janine's fox news show and it is
as wacky and weaponized as you could
imagine so let's get right into it you
won't be surprised Franklin Graham says
it is sin that has caused the virus
judge Jeanine loves it let's break it
all down and to Janine's credit she asks
a good question why would God allow
coronavirus to happen she's not asking
the question in good faith she's teeing
up a specific answer for Graham but at
least she's asking the question take a
listen
given the number of Americans and
thousands have already died you know do
you you must get questions like why
would God allow this kind of thing to
happen well I don't think it's God a
plan for this to happen is because of
the sin that's in the world Judge man
has turned his back on God we have
sinned against him and we need to ask
for God's forgiveness and that's what
Easter is all about is about God so
loving the world that He gave His only
begotten
sun-god didn't plan it the sin caused it
to happen judge says Franklin Graham and
notice him throwing Easter in there
Easter of course sort of cancelled since
the country will remain closed no doubt
many churches in certain parts of the
country will be filled with people on
Easter regardless so then Franklin
Graham continues with this line of
reasoning and if you're watching pay
attention to the look on judge Janine's
face like this is some incredible new
idea that Franklin Graham is putting out
there that whosoever believeth in him
should not perish but should have
everlasting life Jesus Christ came to
save sinners he didn't come to condemn
the world but to save the world and if
we put our faith and trust in him now
he'll forgive our sins and he'll heal
our hearts and he'll change the course
of our lives and this this pandemic this
is a result of a fallen world a world
that has turned his back on God and so I
would encourage people to pray and just
let's ask God let's ask God for help
well Franklin Graham I don't think
there's any question but this is giving
people a tremendous opportunity to be
somewhat introspective there it is if we
trust Jesus he will forgive our sins and
it'll change our lives and the pandemic
is because we've turned our back just
pray praying is the solution so there
are going to be people who see this and
they will say quite simply there's
nothing wrong with this it's a man of
faith and he says we must maintain our
faith through the crisis that's not what
Franklin Graham is doing here Franklin
Graham is appearing on a channel that's
been minimizing and downplaying the
pandemic from day one and then they feed
to their audience a guy who says the
virus is caused by sin and solved by
prayer and we need Jesus in our lives at
this particular time the solution is
social distancing letting the medical
experts tell us what to do work on
therapeutics work on a vaccine science
and staying the hell home those are the
solutions
and when these Fox News viewers hear
Franklin Graham insists the cause
sin and the solution is prayer they are
more likely to keep packing the churches
and potentially becoming super spreaders
of the disease and that dumb look on
judge Janine's face like what a
breakthrough incredible breakthrough
from Franklin Graham here on the virus
it's disgusting yes but it's not
altogether surprising for judge Jeanine
the message is this isn't about anything
other than people didn't pray correctly
or they didn't pray enough and it's
actually flat-out vile to be
perpetuating that idea what about all of
the good praying Christians by the way
who did die of the virus
I guess according to Graham they weren't
praying hard enough or their sins
outweighed the prayer or they pray to
the wrong God or work God works in
mysterious ways or what you're not
allowed to ask that that's an offensive
question to people like Franklin Graham
the problem is in reality almost the
opposite of what Franklin Graham says
too many people are ignoring science and
doctors the problem is not people are
ignoring Jesus too many people are
ignoring science and doctors and instead
they're listening to pastors and
clueless presidents like the one that we
have and of course this is a
one-size-fits-all explanation for these
religious nuts Jerry Falwell after 9/11
said it was the abortionists and the
gays that caused 9/11 to happen others
said the same thing about HIV oh
definitely sin was the reason for HIV
these are horrible people they are only
making the problem worse and Fox News
continues to incubate for lack of a
better term these ideas and
unfortunately again sticking with the
viral vocabulary a lot of Fox News
viewers have been inoculated against
reason and rationality and they take
this stuff as if it were gospel which
Franklin Graham of course probably
believes it to be
unless he's just a straight-up grifter
which he may be in which case he's a bad
person rather than delusional you often
can't really tell with these guys so we
have no shortage of gaslighting in 2020
and specifically around the pandemic but
what really takes the cake in my view is
that
Fox News has now started to pretend that
they never downplayed the virus that
they never said it was a hoax that they
never said it was a great time to get on
an airplane or to go to a restaurant
because there wouldn't be anybody else
there they are pretending they never
gave platforms to any right wing clowns
that wanted to minimize the virus and
defend President Trump and they are now
trying to revise history much like
Donald Trump has tried to do and they
are doing it because they're starting to
get sued for having spread coronavirus
disinformation here's Sean Hannity
remember Hannity famously put up an
image a few weeks ago bragging about
coronavirus deaths zero
here's Hannity the same night ridiculing
everyone who took this seriously
from day one tonight I can report the
sky is absolutely falling we are all
doomed the end is near the apocalypse is
imminent and you're going to all die all
of you in the next 48 hours and it's all
president Trump's fault
here's Hannity again downplaying it on
March 9th in all seriousness I think
we've got to be very real with the
American people I don't like how we are
scaring people unnecessarily and that is
that unless you have a commune system
that's compromised and you are older and
you have other underlying health issues
you are not going to die 99 percent from
this virus correct that's great and it's
good to be with you again all right so
that's the point I mean with this
hearing the living hell out of people
and I I see it again as like oh let's
bludgeon Trump with this new cloaks that
was Republican bomb throwing Trump
sycophant congressman Doug Collins very
much agreeing with sean hannity's
assessment but most importantly Hannity
actually calling it a hoax
now here's Hannity 11 days later saying
he was always taking it seriously yeah I
think what kind of laugh at it another
laugh at here by the way this program
has always taken the coronavirus
seriously and we've never called the
virus a hoax we call what they're doing
trying to bludgeon the president out
there politicizing of this virus
well predictable despicable repulsive
all of the above here are other segments
from fox news including Jeanine Pirro
saying coronaviruses proof merely of an
anti-trump agenda hannity calling the
virus a political weapon the now fired
host trish regan we'll get to her later
saying the left is stoking chaos Laura
Ingraham saying the virus is a leftist
smear campaign and on and on and on
here's lunatic Jesse waters downplaying
it on March 3rd you want to know how I
really feel about the corona virus one
if I get it I'll beat it I'm not lying
it's the cold the power of positive
thinking and I think America needs to
wake up to that I'm not afraid of the
corona virus and no one else should be
that afraid either and then here's the
same Jesse waters not even a month later
on April 1st pretending he was always
taking it seriously but there were some
Democrats who weren't taking it
seriously Cuomo was saying go eat out in
New York City de Blasio had all the
schools open Nancy Pelosi said bring
your friends to Chinatown and go to the
bars Joe Biden said the travel ban was
racist every column in the New York
Times The Washington Post downplayed
this thing and actually morning Joe had
the audacity the other day to say that
everybody saw this coming in January
June omni's segments
morning joe did on the virus in january
1 they booked a guy who said don't worry
about this virus worry about the flu
finally everyone's on board young people
old people left right we're all in this
together now and we need to stay
together until we be so now Jesse waters
saying he was one of the few people
taking it seriously all along they are
now gaslighting we could do examples of
this all day long and they're simply
taking the lead from Trump this is what
you have to really understand about this
entire sort of echo chamber for weeks
Trump downplayed the virus and so did
Fox News so did Rush Limbaugh so did
everybody now Trump
is pretending he never downplayed it
pretending he always took it seriously
pretending he always knew it was going
to be a pandemic think he said last week
he knew it was a pandemic before it was
even being said publicly and so now Fox
News is doing the exact same thing
they're very predictable caricatures in
a sense truly sad state of affairs in
the country but all of this is
completely predictable when it comes
down to knowledge and facts and thinking
this was exactly what we would have
assumed that they were going to do and
of course the real concern the serious
issue at the tail end of this whenever
we get to it is that they may get away
with it they have a confident dishonest
ignorant is the the kind of best way I
can summarize it they are dishonest they
are ignorant to the facts but they do so
confidently on their airwaves and
unfortunately unless we have a long
memory
they may not suffer because of it and so
my greatest fear is of course that the
death toll will be so much higher than
it needed to be because of the terrible
is terrible response from the president
and the terrible responses that we saw
from the right-wing media that basically
just played to trump space that's
concern number one the death toll once
it's all said and done and it's time to
decide are we real acting Trump or are
we voting him out I worry that that
confident irresponsible ignorant
dishonesty will lead to too many people
saying would have been worse without
Trump let's vote to re-elect him and
that is genuinely an increasing fear
that I have because of the degree to
which that cultish following of Trump is
convinced that he's been doing the right
thing all along we'll keep following it
and trying to make the case that that is
not the situation so yesterday there
were some really interesting moments
during Donald Trump's coronavirus press
briefing one of them was when within
minutes Donald Trump went from saying
I'm withholding money from the w-h-o to
denying that he ever said that we
already looked at that
I mostly have not been playing clips
from these press briefings each day
because if I did the entire show would
be clips from the press briefings which
have essentially replaced Donald Trump's
political rallies in the era of
coronavirus as a way for him to get out
his propaganda and he probably to some
degree kind of like gets off from doing
these press briefings would be my guess
but yesterday there were a couple of
things that I really want to highlight
because they go beyond the coronavirus
story alone and they bleed over into
some other important issues one being
the November of 2020 election and how to
do it safely and the idea of voting by
mail now Nancy Pelosi has already said
we should vote by mail in 2020 I played
that clip for you last week coronavirus
makes it dangerous for people to mass
gather at polling places although we are
expecting a decline starting very soon
that will go through July August we're
not exactly sure until when in November
we will likely be in the second wave of
coronavirus cases but Donald Trump has
been very critical of voting by mail why
well we know why he admitted it because
it would help Democrats win and you
don't have to take my word for it here
is Trump himself saying that exact thing
just last week I won't tell you this if
you look at before and after the things
they had in there were crazy they had
things and levels of voting that if he
ever agreed to it you'd never have a
Republican elected in this country again
they had things in there about you know
election days and what you do and all
sorts of clawbacks
and they had things that were just
totally crazy and had nothing to do with
workers that lost their jobs
alright so we know Trump knows voting by
mail would be bad for Republicans that
would be bad for him so yesterday during
the coronavirus press briefing he again
went on about how vote-by-mail is bad
vote-by-mail is corrupt vote-by-mail is
fraudulent but a reporter accurately
pointed out that and this was being
carried live on Fox News and on other
networks mind you a reporter points out
wait a second mr. president you voted by
mail in Florida just a few days
ago if it's so bad and corrupt why is it
that you're doing it and Trump says the
quiet part out loud admitting well it's
okay for me to do it it's just not okay
for other people to do it take a look at
this video I could vote by mail further
because I'm allowed to
well that's called out of state you know
why I voted because I happened to be in
the White House and I won't be able to
go to Florida and look well there's a
big difference between somebody that's
out of state and does a ballot and
everything sealed certified and
everything else you see what you have to
do with the certifications and you get
thousands and thousands of people
sitting in somebody's living room
signing about mail-in voting is horrible
and corrupt but I'm allowed to do it
Trump clearly imploding here and tries
to wildly suggest well you know I'm
doing it from out of state and all of
these other people are talking about
doing it in state all else being equal
though isn't it safer to do in-state may
vote by mail because the ballots have to
travel a smaller distance a shorter
distance doesn't that I mean it's like
it's not really a big difference but it
seems that if anything vote by mail
within the state is less risky than what
Donald Trump is doing it's absolutely
and completely incoherent and I'm
actually surprised Fox News didn't cut
away from this altogether mail-in
ballots are good and convenient for
Trump but they're bad for everybody else
now if we had a reasonable president if
we had a real president at all I think
maybe is more accurate the president
would realize we have a pandemic and a
top priority is we need a safe option
for voting it should be transparent
vote-by-mail is not corrupt let's start
now or really weeks ago setting up
vote-by-mail in every state for
everybody for November but Donald Trump
has already admitted vote-by-mail would
be bad for him it would be bad for
Republicans and he's right about that
why Democrats are more likely to believe
the science on coronavirus Republicans
are more likely to repeat to believe
Donald Trump's propaganda Democrats are
more likely to heed Warren
about social distancing so if November
comes around and we're in wave two of
the virus and things are dicey there is
no doubt that Democrats are more likely
to stay home than Republicans if
everyone has a safe convenient secure
way to vote from home
Trump realizes accurately it's not good
for him that's why we have what we have
today which is Trump calling
vote-by-mail dangerous and corrupt but
of course he's doing it and the only way
in which voting by mail is dangerous is
that it makes it more likely Trump is
removed in the fall which we desperately
need and Trump is increasingly desperate
to prevent very very difficult stuff
that we are dealing with and these are
some of the side stories which aren't
even really side stories that really
deserve a lot of attention we'll have
more on this and today's other stories
on the David Pakman show
Instagram page at David Pakman show do
me a favor while you're there follow me
on instagram at david pakman you may not
have heard I am now the poster boy for a
hair product you'll know what what I
mean if you check out my Instagram at
David Pakman quick break back after this